let's start with a
tweet from neil degrasse tyson
stating his skepticism about aliens
wanting to visit earth
quote how egocentric of us to think that
space aliens who have mastered
interstellar travel across the galaxy
would give
pardon the french
would give a [ __ ] about humans on earth
so let me ask you would aliens care
about visiting earth observing
communicating with humans
let's take a perspective of aliens maybe
sarah
uh
first are we interesting in the whole
spectrum of life in the universe
i'm completely biased at least as far as
i think right now we're the most
interesting thing in the universe um so
i would expect um based on the intrinsic
curiosity that we have
and how much i think that's deeply
related to the physics of what we are
that other intelligent aliens would want
to seek out examples of the phenomena
they are
to understand themselves better and i
think that's kind of a natural thing to
want to do and i don't think there's any
kind of judgment on it being a lesser
being or not it's like saying you have
nothing to learn by talking to a baby uh
you have less to learn probably more
than you two talking to somebody that's
90. so um
yeah so i think they absolutely would so
whatever the phenomena is
that is human
there will be an inkling of the same
kind of phenomenal within alien species
and then we'll be seeking that same
i think there's got to be some features
of us that are universal and i think the
ones that are most interesting and i
hope i live in an interesting universe
are the ones that
are driven by
our curiosity and the fact that
our intelligence allows us to do things
that the universe wouldn't be able to do
without things like us
existing we're going to define a lot of
terms one of them is interesting yes
that's very interesting term to try to
define uh lee what what do you think are
humans interesting for aliens
well let's take it from our perspective
we want to go find aliens as a species
quite desperately
so
if we put the shoe on the other foot of
course we're interesting
but i'm wondering
um and assuming that we're at the right
technological capability to go searching
for aliens
then that's interesting so what i mean
is if there needs to be a massive leap
in technology that we don't have
how will aliens prioritize coming to
earth and other places but i i do think
that they would come and find us because
they want to find out about our culture
what things are universal it what about
i mean i'm a chemist so i'd say well is
the chemistry universal right
are the creatures that we're going to
find making all this commotion
are they made of the same stuff
um
what does their science look like um
are they off planet yet um i guess
there's so i i think that neil degrasse
tyson is being slightly pessimistic and
maybe trying to play
the
tune that the universe is vast and it's
not worth them coming here i don't think
that
but i just worry that maybe we we don't
have the ability to talk to them we
don't have the universal translator we
don't have the right physics but sure
they should come we are interesting i
want to know if they exist it would make
it easier if they just came
you